here's a fun fact about NYC murder is up
55% this year sorry that's not a fun
fact that's a terrifying fact especially
if you live in New York or are a tourist
of which we get 60 million yearly from
the start of 2019 there's been 48
killings almost one per day last year at
this time there were 31 thankfully Mayor
Bill DeBlasio aka Captain lurch is here
announcing all public schools will be
going meatless on Mondays I bet this is
important on so many levels this is
important on so many levels but it's I
gotta say if you're thinking about our
kids individually we want them to be as
healthy as they can be and we want them
to learn as well as they can learn and
meatless Monday's will help it'll create
more balance in their lives we're
talking about our climate the
existential threat of global warming
this is something we do
that's another contribution to
addressing global warming to striking
more of a balance in our whole society
so cutting back on meat will help save
the planet so would eliminating the
cross-country tour he plans to take
pumping his far left tripe but when
things aren't going too well at home
best to run away between the crime and
his own scandals I'd leave - yeah in
case you missed it the mayor shoveled
nearly 900 million bucks into his wife's
mental health initiative that's nuts
since we've still yet to figure out
where the money went they take the
subway you know it's not mental health
and that's criminal fact is the city we
actually love needs help but it's run by
left-wing Democrats so the mentally ill
are left to languish because the left
has made it acceptable to languish
meanwhile crime creeps back up while
Amazon in 25,000 jobs flee only New York
is it cool to embrace ideologies that
kill jobs if not people the good news
lurch his only mayor of New York the bad
news he's headed your way
barring tofu you know I'm gonna go to
the vegetarian first
Jesse no you know what I understand I
always thought that cafeterias were
always meatless because that wasn't meat
that was mystery meat it was mystery
meat yeah it was like weird stuff I
don't think animals exist agree
that meets no Oh somebody's sponsored by
big meat I want him to be the mayor not
our lunch lady this city is a mess you
can't drive anywhere they've lost 25
thousand jobs with Amazon he can't even
handle a snowstorm people are leaving
for lower taxes stay out of our food
choices mr. mayor this is a publicity
stunt if kids have pasta on Monday it's
not going to reduce the earth's
temperature you pointed out where their
body weight right if he cuts back on the
private jet flights that would reduce
more emissions the only thing he's
worried about is cows getting murdered
not people getting murdered the whole
thing is a joke
kids need protein they're gonna have
cereal for breakfast they're gonna have
lentils for lunch and then the student
athletes are supposed to go out and
perform go to the weight room hit the
court these kids are gonna pass out I
mean even the speech team is gonna pass
out that speech they'll be speechless
without the meat listen speechless all
right Jackie you're the actual vegan
here I will say this that like you could
get fat as a vegetarian because carbon
its carbohydrates not protein but I know
that he's making an environmental claim
yeah tater tots and french fries are
what they're gonna catch yeah one thing
he would never do this but make your
meatless Fridays and then that would be
a head that would help Catholics who
don't eat any meat but you know what
that steaming sack of cooked cabbage
would never ever do that because again
it would be religious in some way shape
or form it number two if he's worried
about saving Mother Earth make the
subways run let people avoid get in
their cars and get over the subways and
I get their faces cut or pushed and
thrown in front of a moving train and it
shouldn't take two and a half hours to
get 60 miles from Connecticut into New
York City he's got his priorities
misplaced he's worrying about people
well having a damned hamburger you know
Dana I actually want all my tax money to
go to mental health I think that's like
I don't I can't think of anything more
important but if
we went that's what I'm saying it's like
that's what bugs me about this is that I
tried to look and find out where all
this money went so that that means that
money that's almost a double crime these
announcement announcement about the 900
million into the mental health was on
the same week that they announced that
the mayor had seven hundred and seventy
three million dollars for a renewal
project for schools also deemed a
failure like that's that money down the
drain and also but lentils is protein
but kids need protein no but think is
lentil that's not gonna fill you up yes
let's see some varsity football players
either lentil soup for lunch and get out
in the fields there are now a bunch of
NFL and NBA players who don't eat meat
and so I don't think that they don't win
championship art from the bashing of
Bill DeBlasio which i think is unfair
crime in this town you should know is
down eight percent this year and most of
these murders were talking about
gang-related in one section North
Brooklyn but they don't matter it's kind
of racist why I love I love playing
along when the five bashes people in
this and said I guess they think the big
guy you don't bash it is a liberal so
they did going after the Blasio
but I will say this I think a pothole as
big as a refrigerator in front of my
apartment I have every right Pio
devotion you should go to Detroit and
and Baltimore and check out some other
cities this city we're better than
Detroit this town is attracting more
young people more people out from Amazon
ratings growing up and jobs are getting
this is at this town is a boomtown but
anyway my key point is the health of
these kids I think what de Blasio saying
about climate change ridiculous but I
think when it comes to saying the kids
hey you're being pushed hamburgers on
your hot dogs take a day break from
eating meat that's a good any of these
students daddy that's the problem he's
the mayor he can make this call that's
why your organs the Mayor McCheese the
anti Mayor McCheese